yeah hello welcome to this video the
Turkish star I recently played this guy
don't remember how it how it went he's
got no name ma'am and I have one win no
I have know when I've got a loss and
draw against him uh-huh c5 interesting
if i take he might take on c3 it's an
interesting move water I don't like d5
Bishop takes and then f5 before maybe if
I am I I expect something like Bishop g4
to happen no this one
no I think I'm going going to push this
it's interesting interesting interesting
line here 90 x pawn takes Knight b5
queen bee six probably is good so yeah
just develop should you form and be sure
to wear yes mom yep creative way to play
the opening black flag should be bad
shape looks kind of kind of okay
yeah i think i'll click with the bishop
it's no need to damage the pawn
structure wow it's still some kind of
been only and shouldn't be bad for white
with space and well the pair of bishops
is not very relevant at the moment but
it's it's it's still a factor ok it
doesn't mind to lose castling rights I
wonder just Queen a for castles sorry
Queen 84 king of age yeah I cannot go
rook be one unfortunately as it takes a
three and see through his check it's a
bit awkward to cover see pawn ma'am i
guess i guess i have to do that it's not
exactly what I wanted no Knight a 3g
takes is mandatory hmm and that's not
good very interesting way of playing
Queen a for now it's got pressure on c3
and Jeff and so maybe maybe I do that
it's not it's not great but there was
trash on c3 and c4 I couldn't really
didn't see anything very attractive and
me this is also not very attractive but
what can you do one point you have to
just go for something it might be okay
if I get in eighth a three before before
immediately no I think I'm going to
prepare this I thing I think I'm okay I
think I'm okay you can check their icy
going to go a five all right let's know
Brooksie one is a bad idea that's
probably all so bad well okay let's play
before
check hmm that's simple and good I guess
g3 Bishop g2 after this nice Bishop is
pretty bad and that night don't like the
night down the edge of the board and
maybe regroup at like be 23 years old
now you can go see a double on the C
file and try to threaten no use 6 so
thatís idea something with need six Jim
am I really in bad shape I don't know I
think it should be kind of okay he's
more comfortable yeah but it's nothing
particularly threatening five
it was a night that was my idea covering
f2 and this Bishop isn't so bad on age
30 the only thing that worries me is 34
porn oh that's in surprising okay maybe
it's just that I'm not good enough but I
wonder sometimes how you can decide so
quickly on a move like you can three it
can easily also just be bad for black is
that the point is kind of kind of on its
own so let's close this down
time margins that's an interesting
hmm
ok one
now F 293 rook f3 I Scott look III
that's my that's a problem I didn't see
rookie 3-inch back still not entirely
clear check
rook g3 this is this this ice is just in
time he's just in time King g5 king of
three and then he can take everything
and it's not enough i guess Jack not his
cover he's got you one covered it was
lost anyway I think Riza yeah 3 was a
very committal move and a rook f3 but it
might maybe it was good I mean sloth I'm
amazed that you can do that in in in one
second okay the computer since it's
rubbish as I as I expected but I didn't
play it right mmm so should take first
here not quite sure what the point is
okay boutiques be takes I'm may be
invading I don't know that possible
that's a very very tough position check
well then I've got here okay yeah i win
the pawn just win the pawn so he has to
go back and then this one hmm tough
that's right I'm engine likes white but
yeah I have porn not easy this is wrong
already yeah maybe I should lose that
time a g5 is very strong of course now
aged five g4 is losing take skin g6
there there and after the Sun probably
lost em check check here you here i'm
probably lost now then it's losing
f3 was very risky aruget 3 was very
risky because of this B takes you five
business but yeah I already don't know a
very very tough position that g-force is
still a strange move I think but anyway
a look at one and here what's the
computer gives b5 that's an amazing move
I have no squares no square yeah the
deaths that's why nights are sometimes
not so great oh wow yep if I go here the
rookie is lost amazing amazing b5 is
very strong nobody played this instantly
and now I should take and take on c5 so
this is what the engine is recommending
was just a slight edge for white and
night f2p thats it looks good maybe I
can go over to h2
I mean the idea would be to do something
like this the round round term and yeah
something like this and now go here here
and then grab it now black is active
maybe you can you can probably survive
it Jen somehow that that opening didn't
go so well I wonder what happened down
there is this
the engine gives this move I just this
this Andrew p7 maja what's not exactly
intuitive 52 here we create for sketchup
who i am i know and then you were when i
played it but I couldn't really find
something that I liked I Queen d3 is
actually a good move I didn't think
about that one covering both both down
c4 NC three yeah that looks like an
improvement actually that is an
improvement with white maybe being yeah
maybe I'm a bit better with my space
check yeah he's definitely definitely
okay now tough game thanks for watching